[MUSIC PLAYING]
WAYNE PIEKARSKI:
I'm Wayne Piekarski,
and I'm a developer
advocate here at Google.
DAVE SMITH: I'm Dave Smith.
I'm also a developer
advocate here at Google.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI:
And so today, we're
going to be talking about how
to make your own custom Android
Things boards.
So we showed you
during previous talks,
if you may have
seen them or not,
how it's possible that you can
create your own custom hardware
designs.
And you can start from
a simple prototype,
but you can then take it
into a full production device
that you could then
sell commercially.
So let's get started
talking about that.
So in the sandbox area, you may
have seen this little candle
demo that we've
got set up there.
If you haven't been
to the sandbox area,
definitely go and
check that out.
But it's an example of a little
LED candle that Dave built.
And so basically, you've
got a little Android Things
SOM on there, and it
flickers the lights.
And that's a little candle.
So he built a plastic
housing for it.
You can put it inside of it.
It looks really cool.
So you can go check
that out in the sandbox.
But it's a project that Dave
started working on recently,
and it's something that
he built from scratch
because Dave's a talented
electronic engineer
and I just pretend to be
one on a day-to-day basis.
But the thing I like
about it is it's
a really compelling
example of how
to make something
really simple that
fits within the development
model of Android Things.
And so you can think of it
as kind of a Hello World
example for Android Things, a
basic setup that does something
very simple that you
can then expand and do
more with later on.
And it turns out that
building something like this
is actually reasonably possible
for a hobbyist developer
at home using a set
of simple tools.
You don't need a
factory or anything
crazy to build
something like this.
And everything we're
showing you in this talk--
we're going to show
you all the steps--
but everything's open source.
So later on, Dave will
show you the links
of where you can go to find
the information about how
to get it.
But everything's open
source, so you can modify it.
You can study it.
And we want to show
you how this works
a bit because hardware
design is one of those things
that I've always found is
kind of shrouded in mystery.
And so for software
developers, a lot of people
think, oh wow,
hardware is really hard
and it's really scary.
And I've always
thought that too.
And it's actually not
an imagined problem.
It's actually based
on real things.
It's really complicated to
build high-speed electronics.
If you look at a modern
motherboard or circuit board,
there's tons of these
really fine pitch tracks.
You can see on this
schematic on the screen here
a bit of an example.
And there's a lot
of dense packaging.
There's impedance-matching
requirements,
and there's noise and
interference considerations.
And these are all
things you have
to deal with when you're
building a circuit that
runs at very high speed.
Now, if you're building
just an LED and a battery,
that's pretty simple.
That's not high-speed.
But when you're
building something
that's vibrating at a
gigahertz or some frequency,
you really need to start
thinking about these issues.
And one of the
interesting things
Dave's pointed out
to me when we started
this talk was if you
look at the bottom right
underneath that
semiconductor chip there,
there are these traces that
are like, wiggling around.
Now, that's not an accident.
A very smart, intelligent design
person looked at that and went,
we need to match impedances and
deal with the speed of light
of an electron
traveling on a wire,
and they did that on purpose.
But I didn't know you
had to even do that.
And so if I made that
board, without that,
it wouldn't have worked.
So this stuff's really
tricky, but it turns out,
though, that with the
way we do Android Things,
we can solve a lot
of those problems
and make them easy for us
developers to play with.
DAVE SMITH: Thanks, Wayne.
So as Wayne mentioned,
one of the things
that's sort of a core
philosophy of ours
when it comes to
enabling developers
to help build hardware
using Android Things
is this idea of a
System on Module
or a SOM-based architecture.
And we really think of
this as one of the keys
to developer success in
terms of building hardware.
And it has a lot to do with
what Wayne just mentioned.
So let me kind of walk
you through this idea
and give you some examples here.
So if you were to look at
a typical developer kit
that you would buy
for Android Things,
it might look
something like this.
And what you may or may not
notice just looking at this
is this is actually two
different boards stuck
together.
So if I explode those out a
little bit, what you can see
is that we actually have
this larger baseboard,
or what we often refer
to as a carrier board,
and then the smaller
modules sitting on top.
And that's what we refer
to as a system on module,
a SOM, or a compute module.
And that module has all of
the compute, the connectivity,
and the storage hardware
that is essentially
everything that's
required to build
a specific tiny,
little computer.
And that's where all the hard
stuff lives from an electronics
perspective.
That's where all the
high-speed stuff is.
All those impedance requirements
that Wayne just mentioned,
all of those things live
on that little module.
And the only piece that you're
responsible for as a developer
building a new product
is to essentially design
your own version of
the baseboard that
applies whatever is specific
to your application.
So you might just have a
handful of little I/O pieces,
maybe some connectors for power.
The reason that the baseboard
design with the developer kit
is so large is because it
has all the possible I/O that
could ever come off of this
chip expanded out so that it's
easy for you to work with.
You can connect pieces
where you need them.
But when you go into
production with your design,
you can make this much,
much smaller and much more
compact based on just the
elements that you need to apply
for your specific application.
OK, one of the other really big
things that people don't always
think about when it comes
to working with SOMs
is this idea that
if you're going
to build an electronic product,
something you're actually
going to sell to
consumers, you have
to actually get that
thing tested for safety
testing, regulatory testing.
These are things that if
you just develop software,
you don't maybe necessarily
have ever thought about.
And this can cost
a lot of money,
and it can waste your
company a lot of time.
Certification testing
for FCC and UL,
things like that, these
can cost on the order
of tens of thousands
of dollars or more.
And one of the issues
that SOMs solve for you
is this idea that these are
pre-certified components
according to all of those
regulatory standards.
So the components are
FCC-certified for all
of the wireless interfaces.
The power supplies and
all of the other things
are safety tested
through CSA and UL
and whatever is required
in your specific country.
And that drastically reduces,
if not completely eliminates,
the requirements for testing
on your final product.
So it's a huge cost-saver to use
these pre-certified components
in your design.
All right, a couple of other
benefits of using a SOM--
one is that, at least with
the SOMs that we work with,
there are a number of
them that are actually
fairly interchangeable.
And this significantly
reduces the amount of rework
that you might have
to do in your design
if you decide to move
to a different platform
or a different vendor.
So a couple examples of
this, first of all, some
of our SOMs--
for instance, the
Intel Edison as well as
both variants of the NXP
Pico that we support--
are actually pin-compatible,
meaning that you can literally
take one off, install the
other one on in its place,
and it will work
exactly the same.
You don't have to
make any changes
to your baseboard hardware
or your custom design.
So if you decide,
for whatever reason,
that you need to move
from the Edison to the NXP
or back and forth,
you don't have
to make any changes to
your hardware to do that.
In some other cases, we
also provide variance
from different vendors so that
you can solve supply chain
issues if you run into them.
So another example is that
Pico board that I mentioned
uses the NXP I.MX 6 chip.
And we have another SOM that
uses the exact same chip called
the Argon.
So you can, again, target a
specific hardware platform,
but if you're having
supply chain problems
getting that
specific module, you
can just go use the
other one in its place.
So it helps you reduce
the amount of rework
you might have in
your design based
on having to deal with some
of these vendor-based issues.
In addition, SOMs are
highly available components.
These are essentially
commodity components
that you can buy
in single quantity,
or a handful at a time,
or in very large quantity
for production.
You're essentially leveraging
the economies of scale
that the vendors
are participating in
on your behalf.
So to give you an example,
if you were to go directly
to a chip vendor and you were
to buy the CPUs yourself,
buy the memory and
all these things
to build this onto your specific
board, generally speaking,
you would have to
buy those components
in very large quantities--
5,000, 10,000 or
more at a time, which
is very prohibitively
expensive for just
doing basic prototyping.
What you do with a
SOM is essentially,
the vendors that
build the modules
absorb that cost for you.
They buy 10,000 of the chips
and then build the modules
and sell them in such a
way that you can buy one
if you need it for
your prototype, or 100,
or 1,000 or even more.
And finally, SOMs
are well supported,
both from Google's
perspective, but also
with the individual vendors.
So all of the vendors
that we work with
have long-term support
contracts in place
so that the hardware that you
choose to build your product on
is guaranteed to be
supported on into the future
so that you don't have to
worry about building something
off a design that goes
into end-of-life next year.
All right, so let's talk a
little bit about the tools
and processes that you
might actually go through
to build one of these things.
So the first stage
generally-- and those of you
who have played
with Android Things
may have done a little
bit of this already.
But when you first decide
to start using the platform
and you want to start
building something,
you're probably
going to purchase
one of our supported
developer kits.
This is an example of one of
them using the Intel Edison.
And from here, you
would generally
use that developer kit
baseboard to just start
prototyping your idea,
generate that proof of concept.
So you're going to
start connecting,
in this case, maybe some
LEDs, some inputs, a display,
whatever you want to do to sort
of test out if this thing is
actually going to work.
And then from there,
you can kind of
carry it around; show it to the
other folks that you work with;
say OK, I think this
idea might actually work.
And then you can move
forward from that process.
Now, there's a couple
of things that you
might be using to build
these particular designs.
One of them is you might
use a breadboard, which
is essentially just a
solderless component that
allows you to stick wires in and
prototype this thing up however
it works for you.
But those types of boards
are not that portable.
Often if you move them
from here to here,
you would lose a connection
because the wire comes loose.
So generally, what we would
typically use in a prototype
that you want to actually
show to someone else
is something called
a protoboard.
And that's what we have
in this example here.
And if you want to get up close
with this particular piece
of hardware, it
is in the Sandbox
along with the final product.
So you can look at that
design up close and kind of
see how it's all put together.
But once you've certified
that your idea is actually
going to work,
you're probably going
to want to actually build
a custom design out of it.
This is really cool and it's
fun to post online and see
all your friends
what you've done,
but that's probably not
something you can ship
in high volume to consumers.
So you need to
redesign that into more
of a custom, compact,
integrated system.
And so in order
to do that, you're
going to be using a
couple of new tools
that you may or may not have
ever worked with before,
and there's two
pieces of content,
or what we call
hardware design files,
that you have to create to
build this custom design.
The first one is called a
schematic, and a layout.
And we're going to
look at both of these
so you get an idea of
what's inside of these.
So a schematic for
an electronic product
is essentially just a
definition of all the components
you want to use and how they
should be connected together.
And this example
that we have up here
is the exact schematic
for that candle sample
that you saw pictured earlier.
And the first thing that
I want you to notice
is there's not really
a whole lot there.
And the reason for
that is because all
of that complicated
hardware that goes along
with the CPU and the memory,
et cetera, is on the module.
So I don't have to add
those pieces to my design.
All I have to design
in are the pieces that
are specific to my application.
So this design has a
connector for the USB which
we use for power, a power supply
to do some voltage changing
from the input to the
output, the connector
for the actual module.
So we don't have
to actually lay out
all of the pieces that
are on that module, just
a single connector where
we stick it onto our board.
And then the I/O
pieces-- in this case,
those little LEDs that we can
blink that you saw in the image
before.
So the schematic is responsible
for defining all of the things
you want to use and how each
of those elements interconnect.
And if you've never
done this before,
there are a number of
tools that are really
good to get started with this.
And I've got them
listed there, so EAGLE--
Altium actually has two products
called the Circuit Maker
and Circuit Studio--
and KiCad.
All of these are very
approachable electronic design
tools that allow you to get
started building schematics.
One of the benefits
of all of these
is they're very well
supported in the community.
So you can get support.
You can find tutorials if you're
not used to dealing with these.
And in addition, all
of these have a lot
of library support online.
So just to give you an
example, this entire schematic
was built in EAGLE,
and all of the parts
came from open source
libraries provided by SparkFun.
So I didn't have to
create any of those parts.
I just used libraries
that already existed.
And when you use tools like
EAGLE, Altium, and KiCad,
you'll find good
support for doing that.
There's actually
another reason why
these are good tools
to choose, and we'll
get to that in a minute.
All right, so you
built the schematic.
This is what I want this
electronic thing to do.
But now, we have
to actually define
what is it physically
going to look like,
and that's what
the layout is for.
So the layout
definition is basically,
you're just drawing
a picture of,
this is what I want the
board to actually be,
where do I want the
components to be placed,
how do I want those
wire connections to be
routed, and get everything
sort of laid out perfectly.
Are there any holes that we
want to drill in the board
so that we can mount
it to something easily?
All of those pieces are
defined by the layout.
And this layout is also
defined in the same tool.
So when you use an electronic
design tool like EAGLE,
you define both the
schematic and the layout
in the same tool.
They're coupled
together very tightly so
that when you make a
change to the schematic,
that can be reflected on
the layout, and vice versa.
Just to give you a picture, if
you've never actually looked
at one of those layouts before,
it might look a little strange.
So I put the physical
board next to it
so you can kind
of get an idea of,
oh OK, this is where
this connector goes,
and these are the
holes for the LEDs.
They're in the middle
in all of that.
So essentially, once you have
a schematic defined and then
a subsequent layout,
this is now something
that you could take to a
vendor or manufacturer,
and you could have
that thing produced.
All right, so I want
to talk about a couple
of different definitions
because there
are two ways that you can
go about actually building
one of these things.
So the first stage that's
pretty much always required
is you have to
fabricate the boards.
So you hear someone talking
about fabricating a PCB
or the fabrication process.
That's essentially just building
the actual base circuit board,
OK?
It's taking that layout,
giving it to a vendor,
and having them
actually etch out
all of the pieces
on the fiberglass,
and lay down the copper, and
all of those things for you
so that you have a basis to
actually build your product.
Then the assembly
process is essentially
just taking that bare board
and installing the components
on top of it.
And there's a couple ways
that this can be done.
The reason that
we've split these out
is because you
generally probably
don't want to try and
fabricate your own PCBs.
There are people who do
it and there are tools
that you can do to do that.
But generally, that's a
process best left to a vendor,
and it's relatively inexpensive
to be able to do this,
even in low volume.
But you might decide, for
cost reasons or time reasons
or whatever, that
it's easier for you
to assemble the board yourself.
So you might decide to
simply buy the components
and solder them down by hand or
using any other tools that you
might have available to you.
But you can also have a vendor
do this for you as well.
So a little bit later on, we'll
look at some different options
around where you might be able
to just get the PCBs fabricated
themselves versus having them
completely fully assembled
and delivered to you with
all those pieces in place.
All right, so I mentioned
schematic and layout before.
You could sort of think
of these design files
as the source code
for your hardware.
These are the pieces
that you develop.
And then from
there, those can be
fed into a number
of different tools
to generate the
content or the files
necessary to actually have these
pieces manufactured or created.
There's a couple
other terms that I
want you to be familiar
with if you're toying around
with hardware at all.
So the first is Gerbers.
A Gerber file is
a generated file
that is used by
CNC manufacturers
to actually build your board.
It's what takes your
layout, turns it
into a bunch of
CNC instructions,
and then a machine goes
around and puts drills down
and etches out all the pieces
on the board and all of that.
So it's essentially
the generated file that
turns into your finished PCB.
The BoM and the XYRS files are
used in the assembly process.
So BoM stands for
Bill of Materials,
and it's essentially just a
list of all the components
on your board, and the part
numbers of those boards
so that you can purchase
those, and how many of them
are on each particular design.
And then the XYRS file basically
is an automated file that tells
a computer-- in this case,
it's a machine called
a pick-and-place place machine--
how to take those
components, pick them up,
and drop them on your board.
It's the exact
location, rotation,
and all of that where
the component needs
to sit so that it
can be assembled
in the right location.
So each of these files are
necessary in some cases
if you want to fully
automate the production
process of building the board.
You can think of these files
as sort of your compiled code
or your machine code.
However, one of the
issues with these files
is that there's not a lot
of pure standards associated
with each of these.
So there are different
formats for Gerbers.
A BoM could be something
as simple as a CSV file,
or it could be something
way more complicated.
And different vendors are going
to have different requirements
about how you produce those
files so that they can import
them into their systems.
So this turns out
not being quite as
simple as you might imagine.
And so generally
speaking, if you're just
getting started with
this or you just
want to do some very
quick basic prototyping,
I recommend finding vendors
that allow you to ignore
these files completely.
And there are a number
of them out there,
and I'm going to show you
a few in just a minute.
But there are a lot of great
PCB and assembly vendors
that will accept your
design files directly.
So the way I'd like to think
of it is if you're new to this
or you're not very
comfortable with it,
and you start going around the
web looking at different places
where you might be
able to build a PCB,
if they ask you for Gerber
files, go look somewhere else.
You'll be able to find someone
that can take your design
files directly so you
don't have to mess
with exporting those and
making sure they're correct
and all of that.
You may get there
eventually, and you might
want to do that at some point.
But at least when
you're getting started,
that's something that you can
ignore completely because there
are a number of great vendors--
and I've highlighted a couple
of them here--
that can take these
directly for you.
So on the fabrication
side, one of the ones
that we've used early in
prototyping is OSH park.
And this is a great vendor,
one, because they'll
accept your EAGLE files,
your Altium files,
et cetera, directly
so you don't have
to deal with all those Gerbers.
But they're also very
low cost in low volume
because they're what we
call a shared PCB vendor.
And what essentially
that means is
that when you give them a board
to make, they take your design
and they take designs from other
customers that were submitted
at the same time,
and they panel them
all up together on one big piece
to run through the machine.
So they reduce the cost for
you because they're actually
running your design along
with others at the same time.
That works really
well for prototyping
because it means you can get
low quantities at low cost.
It has some disadvantages and
lead time because it generally
means you can't get things
that quickly because they have
to wait for other designs
to come along that they
can panel up together.
So you generally can't get
something next day or the day
after that with OSJ
Park, but it works really
well for making sure your
board is actually correct
before you go and actually
have it fully assembled.
One of the common
issues with hardware
is when you build
your design, you
might have accidentally
crossed a couple of wires.
And unfortunately,
unlike with software,
we can't just delete
and recompile that.
We have to actually scratch
off the trace, jumper or wire,
or just throw the boards
away and make some new ones.
So until you're certain that the
schematic you made is correct,
it's good to stick with very
low-cost vendors like this
and hand-assemble the
prototypes until you
know for sure that
what you designed
has everything in
the right place.
On the assembly side,
there are a number
of vendors that also
make this easy that we've
worked with in the past.
I've got CircuitHub and
MacroFab listed up here.
CircuitHub is an
interesting one.
It's essentially like
GitHub for hardware.
They allow you to upload
your design files,
and then you can share that
design under an open source
license.
Other people can
fork that design.
And you can even buy
those designs directly
from the web site.
So they are an assembly
vendor as well as a way
for you to sort of share designs
between folks in the community.
And you'll see actually
a little bit later,
CircuitHub is where we have
uploaded this sample for you
to be able to see the
hardware design files
and play around with it.
MacroFab is another output
vendor that basically
also takes your design files.
And one of the nice
things about MarcoFab
is they do more than just
electronics assembly.
So they will
assemble your boards,
and they're very good at doing
that at low-cost at low volume,
but they will also
assist you in packaging
that into a mechanical
housing or whatever
your final packaging is,
and also can often help you
with inventory as well.
So these actually can be
a really great partner
for a startup building
hardware where
they will help you
sort manage all
of that process along the
way in building your designs,
and maintaining them, and
actually getting them shipped
out to real consumers.
All right, so now
Wayne's going to talk
about what happens when somebody
does this for the first time.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: And how not to
burn your fingers, which I did
multiple times.
To get your prototypes done,
you've got two different steps.
You've got the fabrication
step, and then you've
got soldering the
components onto the board.
So you might have access to
a local company who actually
makes the PCBs where you are.
So you don't--
I mean, the problem with
a lot of these companies
is that sometimes,
they're far away.
They're on the other side of
the country or around the world.
And you don't want to have to
wait a week or a couple of days
to do your shipping.
So sometimes, you want to
do iterative debugging.
Now, when we write source
code on a computer,
we just make a change, type
make, and run it again,
and it takes like three seconds.
But with electronics, there
is this production iteration
that you have to make, which
could take days or weeks
or whatever.
So what we wanted to do
is rather than having
the boards assembled
by someone else,
I wanted to see how
hard it would be
to actually solder them myself.
And so I went to
take Dave's prototype
and try it out to
see if I could do it.
So I've got some kind of
electronics background.
I did electronic engineering
many, many years ago.
But I've only soldered
really large boards
with through-hole mounts.
Those are the ones where the
pin goes through the board.
You can go in with a
huge soldering iron.
And you can make all
kinds of mistakes,
and it doesn't really matter.
So I've done stuff like
that, but I've never
done surface mount before.
So I wanted to see how hard it
would be, what kind of mistakes
I would make, and then
I was going to talk
to you about how we do it.
Now, the most challenging part
is the actual SOM connector
that connects the baseboard
to the little SOM.
And so that's the one
that's the most challenging,
and we're going to
talk a bit about how
we went about soldering that.
So when you look at the SOM
connector, it's really small.
If you look at
these images, those
are images that are shot
through a microscope.
And on the right, you can
see in the microscope I used.
But you can't work with this
thing with your own eyes.
If you actually hold the
SOM connector in your hand,
it's this tiny, little thing.
You can barely see the pins.
And you're like, how am I
ever going to solder this?
So I bought a really cheap
soldering microscope.
They're about $200.
And you basically put
it up to your eyes,
put the board underneath
it, and you can then
see all of the detail in
the board really easily.
Now, it's interesting
because it's actually pretty
surprisingly easy to work with.
You would think that your
hands and everything are
too large to be
able to get in there
and solder something so fine.
But it turns out, when
you're under the microscope,
looking through it,
your body adjusts to it,
and you're actually able
to make pretty fine motions
without too many problems.
Now, what I did find,
though, is that you've
got to anchor your hand
a little bit so you'll
kind of like press one
finger against the table.
And then when you're
under the microscope,
I actually occasionally
touch the soldering iron
under my finger because
everything's so close.
You don't realize how close it
is, so that was kind of fun.
So yeah, a lot of
people around me
were wondering why
I was screaming
from the soldering station.
But anyway, so make sure
you don't drink any coffee
before you do it either,
because that also
gives you the jitters too.
So that's also a protip.
But anyway, so I have
a basic soldering iron.
I have the microscope.
And with that, we're
going to try to start
soldering one of these things.
The problem with a
regular soldiering iron
is that it's too large.
So under a microscope,
on the left,
you can see I've got
a ballpoint pen, which
shows how big a real
pen looks like, the kind
that you write with.
And you can see that the
pen is the size of like five
of the pins on
the SOM connector.
So the tip of the
soldering iron I had
was this big, huge
chisel tip thing
that is designed for
like, I don't know,
soldering huge objects.
But we needed
something really fine.
So you can actually buy a tiny
0.1 millimeter soldering iron
tip, and you can see that
on the right in the image.
So that tip is 0.1
millimeter wide.
And you can see that it
still looks quite big even
compared to the pins on there.
But it turns out, you can
actually solder with this.
And it's funny
because if you take
that soldering tip and stab
your-- not stab yourself,
but prick yourself with
it, it's really sharp.
It feels almost like a needle.
And yet, this thing
under a microscope,
it's got this huge round tip,
and it's kind of incredible.
But anyway, so that's
what it looks like.
You can see how small everything
is relative to the soldiering
iron.
So that's kind of the
challenge that we're dealing
with under the microscope.
So the first thing
you need to do
is when you're doing fine
soldiering like this,
you need to make sure that
the solder sticks to the board
cleanly.
So we use what's
called flux for that.
So most solder
has flux built in.
But doing very fine
connections like this,
you need to have extra flux
to make sure it works nicely.
So you can buy these flux pens.
And actually, the pen fills
up half the microscope
when you're using it
because it's huge.
But anyway, you paste a bit
of flux down on the board,
and then you put the SOM
connector down on top of it.
And you have to maneuver it in
with tweezers or your fingers
or something like that.
And then you've got
to hold it in place
somehow so you can actually
do the soldering operation.
So what you do is you basically
bring the soldering iron up,
like you can see in
this picture here.
You bring it up to the
pin, and then you've
got to bring the solder
in against the pin
at the same time.
Now, what you don't want to do
is touch the solder directly
onto the soldering iron,
because what happens
is the solder just melts and
wicks up the soldering iron
and doesn't go onto
the board itself.
So you need to
make sure that you
touch the solder under the
pins and keep the tip away.
But at the same time,
you've got to touch the wire
to heat it up and make
sure you solder correctly.
So initially when I started, I
had problems getting everything
to flow.
But then Dave talked
to me and said,
you're going to really
angle everything
apart to really
avoid the touching.
The solder itself is
0.4 millimeters wide.
So if you look at the picture,
it's actually quite wide
compared to everything.
So it's possible to
sneak it in there.
And after doing a
bunch of practice runs,
I was actually able
to make it work.
So this picture here
shows a work in progress
as I was working
across the board.
You can see some of the
pins in the bottom right
are not done yet, and
the ones in the top
are finished already.
So this is a zoomed-up
version of that same photo.
So this is actually
the first ever
SOM that I've ever soldered.
So I was like, I'm going
to document this process so
that we can talk about
it here in this talk.
But I mean, I did a pretty
terrible job on some of them
in the top.
But this is literally
my first ever attempt
at soldering pins on a SOM,
so Dave was coaching me
over Hangouts to tell
me some hints as to how
things were working out.
But you can see that
in the top left-ish,
there are some nice pins
there, and then the bottom
left with some better ones.
Now occasionally, you'll notice
there are some pins where I
blobbed the solder across them.
Now, those are bad pins.
If you actually turn the board
on with those pins shorted out
like that, you'll
probably blow it out.
So you've got to make
sure that if you ever
bridge the solder
across the pins,
that you've got to get
in there and use wic--
there's this solder bridge you
can get that sucks solder out.
You can use things like that to
remove solder if you need to.
So anyway, so I had a
rough time getting started.
But after a while, I was able to
do some pretty clean jobs that
look quite nice.
So you probably shouldn't do
this on your very first board
that you're ever making.
But after one or two,
you'll be better at it.
So it's actually
something you can do.
Now, if you look at
the board, there's
actually a lot of
mess around there.
The mess is not the solder.
It's actually residue
from the flux.
The flux is this
shiny material that's
what makes everything
look kind of dirty.
You can clean it a bit.
But we were trying to find
q-tips and other things
to get in there and clean it.
But everything's so fine, you
can't get anything in there
to clean it right.
So we sort of cleaned it,
but the mess that's left over
is the basic residue
from the flux.
So while this is
time-consuming and it
might take a few hours
to do in your own time,
it's actually nice because you
can reduce your debugging time.
You have the ability to take the
boards, solder them yourself,
get it done, do some testing.
And then if you
find mistakes, you
can then use that
ability to make patches.
So in the same way that
we patch source code,
well, you can patch
your hardware as well.
So Dave mentioned before, you
can scratch the tracks away,
solder-wise.
Now, it's not fun to do
this, but it is possible.
And if that saves you
a week, then that's
something that you
can do as well.
And I've seen plenty
of boards where you
see a wire running across them.
It's like, why is
that there for?
And it's like,
well, the designer
forgot to put something in, like
a magic pad or something that
did something right.
And it's the equivalent
of writing code and then
leaving one semi-colon
out, except that semi-colon
is the one that powers the
circuit and does the work.
So you don't have
a compiler that's
going to run your circuit to
tell you if it's going to work.
So you really have
to be careful.
So yeah, you got to
really think about that.
So here is a microscope
shot of one of the boards
that Dave had
professionally fabricated.
So you can see there that
everything looks super clean.
Like, you can tell that a
machine is just gone and laid
the solder down perfectly.
And the way some of these
machines work is they
actually put a solder
paste down on the board.
They put SOM connector
on top, and then they
put it through a reflow
oven that melts the solder
and attaches the components.
So you end up with a
really, really clean joint.
And when you buy professionally
made electronics,
it tends to look
a lot like that.
So my soldering job,
obviously you're
not going to put that circuit
onto the space shuttle
and fly that.
But in this case here, this is
a nice, reliable circuit where
everything is nicely soldered.
So it's not done by
a newbie like me.
And then you attach the SOM onto
the board and you power it up,
and the lights start blinking.
And then we have that
demo in the Sandbox.
And then you can
stand back and bask
in the warming glow of the
Android bounce interpolator.
So the sample Dave
put together, it
uses the bouncing interpolator
to make the LEDs flicker.
And you can hold your
hands in front of it
and get that warm, cozy feeling.
So it's a nice, simple example
because on the software side,
we can do whatever we
want with the LEDs.
But it's like a
Hello World in that
it does something very basic.
It uses basic components, like
a few LEDs and a few resistors.
And now you're on track to
building whatever electronics
that you want to build.
And you can take this, once
you're familiar with it,
and you can expand
on it from there
to do something more
complicated for your needs.
So once you've
built that device,
you need to just think
about the next steps to take
it commercial production.
So before you can sell
a consumer device,
you've got to think
about, well, how
am I going to package
this and enclose it?
And so you might need to find
an industrial designer to make
a plastic housing for you.
You can use a CNC printing
machine to make something,
but those housings don't
tend to be very strong.
So you're probably going
to need to have something
professionally made for that.
Then, when you ship this
device to your customers,
you're going to
need to package it.
So you're going to have to come
up with a cardboard box for it,
maybe some documentation.
It needs to have
padding inside of it
to protect the product
during shipment, maybe
legal documentation.
You've got to get this
stuff made and printed,
and it's not
something you can just
knock up on your laser printer.
It's got to look nice.
And there are industrial
design companies that
help with these final steps.
And then finally,
even little things
like if you need a power supply
or a cable for your device.
You might have to include a USB
charger or something like that.
While they're cheap,
they're not free.
They still cost a
couple of dollars,
and that adds to the
overall cost of the device
that you're selling.
And then finally, every
country has different rules
about what devices they
allow, certifications, safety
requirements, and so forth.
And so for every
country you ship to,
you're going to have to
investigate this and find out
what those processes are.
And so the SOM has had a lot of
testing and certification done
on that, but the overall
packaging and device
needs to also be
checked as well.
So all of these things
I've outlined here
do cost some money,
and it's important
that you think
about these things
before you get started on your
next big crazy startup idea.
And make sure you think about
what the costs are going to be.
And remember that if
you've got a fixed
cost, like $10,000 for
design or certification,
you need to sell enough units
to bury that cost in each one.
If you sell 10,000 of something,
that adds $1 to the price.
But if you're only
making 10 of something,
then it's going to add $1,000
to the price of every unit.
So you need to think about
some of those issues.
And remember, just one
final little point here
is that the nice thing
about Android Things
is we've helped to simplify
the software side of things
as well.
So building an IoT device,
while it might seem easy
and you can build your
own operating system
and put it on there, it comes
at a price in that you still
need to maintain that device and
security updates and so forth.
So one of the nice things
about Android Things
is that you have the
power of Android.
You can use Android Studio.
You can hire phone
app developers
and get them to write
code for your device,
and they can use the
same libraries and tools
that they're familiar with.
So you don't need
to hire someone
who's a micro-controller expert
who writes assembly language.
There's a lot more
programmers available to you.
Also, the SOMs, we provide
updates from Google.
We provide security
updates for them.
We push the updates
out to the devices
so that you don't need to
worry about maintaining
all that stuff yourself.
And then finally, you get all
the power of Android security.
We have a huge team
on the Android team
whose job is to scour the
internet looking for security
problems, and patch Linux
kernels and patch libraries,
and we take care
of that for you.
So now, if you were going to
make the device yourself and do
all the software, you
would have to have
a huge team of security
people and everything
to make sure that's
taken care of.
With Android
Things, we've really
done a lot to help simplify the
software side of things a lot
as well so that you can focus
on what makes your product good
and not have to worry about all
the little details of trying
to secure a device, and push the
updates, and things like that.
DAVE SMITH: So the moral of the
story is if Wayne can do it,
you can probably do it too.
So just a couple of
things to finish up here.
If you're interested in sort of
learning more about the various
hardware platforms that
Android Things does support--
and as we add support for
more, that will be listed here
as well--
you can check out the
hardware support documentation
on the Android dev site.
The candle sample that
you see in the Sandbox,
as we mentioned, is open source.
So the source code and
the hardware design
files themselves are on GitHub.
And the design has also been
uploaded to Circuit Hub, where
you can actually
purchase one of them
directly if you don't even
want to mess with going
through this whole process.
So you can take a look
at those links as well,
and also join our IoT developer
community on G+ so that you can
connect with us.
And Wayne and I are both
there answering questions.
And just give us an
idea of what cool stuff
you're doing so
that we can share it
with the rest of the community.
So we've got a few
minutes for questions.
So if anybody has
any questions, feel
free to hop up to the mics.
And let's see what we got.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: Thank you.
DAVE SMITH: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]